[Music]
oh we're ready we're doing this yes hi
BuzzFeed I'm at the merry Market with
Petco jvm is literally adopting a dog
right now with the holiday season right
around the corner Petco invited BuzzFeed
to their makemore Mary shopping event
where we got to check out some of the
best gifts for all you pet problems out
there with special appearances from
queer eyes Anthony porowski and Jonathan
Van Ness they had everything you could
need for your fur baby from themed
catnip toys to dog leashes with built-in
hand warmers this is so cool
if you feel more cool Tans and adventure
Anthony told us all about their new
brand yummers which is a supplemental
food topper that they sell for both cats
and dogs while Jonathan was off falling
in love with one of the adoptable
puppies on site and honestly so were we
these sweet pups were available for
adoption or fostering through the Muddy
Paws Rescue
all in all it was a successful shopping
day and our fur babies loved their gifts
[Music]